let me ask you a question lex
i believe that every society is supposed
to have a collection
of what i call uh break glass in case of
emergency people yeah
these are people who are universally
loved and trusted by your society for
example david attenborough
the great british naturalist and
presenter uh
recently came on instagram he's worried
about the planet
and i said you know look there are very
few of these people left
let's pay attention find out what he has
to say maybe maybe he's going to be an
ass maybe he's going to be in it maybe
he's going to say wrong things don't
know
tell me about your top 10 universal
american heroes
this is not a rhetorical question no
give me five
everybody looks to that person and says
yep the best of us
well everybody's an interesting concept
i mean
elon musk is very divisive right but
i'm talking about overwhelmingly people
would would follow that person
if that person gave a rousing
intelligent
speech that said we we must act now
because we're in in dire straits
i think a lot of people on that category
for me it would be
uh in the in the tech world in the
engineering world
elon musk elon musk
the rock i'm thinking like who is the
most eloquent actor so like you think
celebrities so people with platforms
don't say celebrities
nobody well known i believe like
platform yeah so
this goes to joe rogan
first two did not really impress me as
being what i said but okay
elon several years ago would have can
you can you try to
joe rogan why do they fail why does why
is
lots of people treat joe rogan as if
he's some sort of right-wing racist
because
they've never watched his program they
don't know his friends i don't know
oh but when i thought you said everybody
i thought you meant
a large enough people where huge change
can happen
not actually literally everybody because
i mean people who've pulled up
like people who've pulled off something
where everybody's convinced that that
person just
deeply
i mean i think i've told you the story
before but
the one time i've seen the power of a
figure
like this i mean very few times i've
been in a large crowd and i've seen
people just
moved where they would do almost
anything good bad and different because
they were primed
one was a rolling stones concert the
other one was nelson mandela
coming to boston and man
you've never seen anything like this
check out the photos from the banks of
the charles river
when nelson mandela came um
there are people that you need in your
dark hours and we can't agree on who
they are and as soon as they emerge we
tar them with [ __ ] we get out the [ __ ]
brunch
yeah i just disagree with you so i think
what do we disagree about it okay
i think it doesn't matter who it is i
think really good speeches are needed
and great think a lot of them i saw
killer mike try to give a good
yeah he did well in atlanta right yeah
he did that was something
very impressed yeah even keller mike
immediately gets into this
sell out like
uh yeah but he he he didn't take up the
responsibility
i would say he didn't of of
going bigger so he was speaking to the
community and he was doing what he did
in this particular moment he's
exceptional at it and he was speaking to
this particular moment
he didn't take it a step farther which
is
like giving the same speech but bigger
than race
bigger than this particular moment but
more about
the the american project you know the
guy who landed the plane in the hudson
yes yeah there you go that's a good
example sorry that guy
until we screw him up
is the kind of thing that i'm talking
about yeah exactly okay i mean jocko
maybe
that's another giaco is pretty good
jaco is pretty good can't really tell is
he a democrat as a republican i don't
know
he's an american that's for damn sure
yeah and i think there's a lot of fun
and then you know no i think jocko there
aren't that's one of the reasons why
chocolate
you